herbert müller setzt man einfach sagen
beim nächsten tag des battle beginn ein
tag 13 minuten oder es wird zu knapp bei
mir scheiße zombie junge mann deswegen
nicht so oft dass ich keine diamanten
finde ich nehme meine sachen und
ziemlich eintönig mit oma aber ich finde
es noch richtig bock dieses wetter ist
auch so die spannung gefällt immer so
groß hier
wer wird den besiegen ich mache jetzt
einfach noch in offenburg abzuwarten
und hier hat alter ist sonne ich hoffe
ich finde die ich finde die schlucht
nochmals kommt die kommentare da werde
ich noch gelesen du scheinst opfer
hauptsache beschreibt dahinter ich hab
sogar noch zeit zu fahren weil ich
einfach weiß dass ich gewinnen werde
er macht einfach ein perfekter coup ist
ein ärgernis
jetzt habe ich hier so viel links junge
ich mache ganz viele halter
ich bin ganz viel helfen jetzt habe ich
eine große klappe aufgerissen ich wette
wenn ich jetzt verpacke meckerte jeder
raum hellrot klappe wie vor kann ländern
verlieren
ja es sind mit recht mit recht einfach
fakt heutige am meisten habe ich angst
vor irgendwelchen monstern ja ich auch
dass du irgendwie welche kommen so auf
einmal doch einfach verrückt vor allem
den creeper diese bastarde nicht wegen
einem oder sterben schneller auf uhren
schmuck centers so und soll dann in den
ofen da oben noch was kann so schön
sehen halter kann es sein dass fraps
wenn man es auf 30 fps eingestellt nur
mit 30 fps aufnimmt ich weiß es nicht
könnte eventuell sein
was denkst du darüber max nein falsch
beide behinderten ist so es ist einfach
so jetzt habe ich die werkbank abgebaut
wo ich noch brauche alter [ __ ] schreibt
natürlich scheiße
sein penis ist gar nicht so bewusst wie
wir mal sagt gar nicht so gut ich kann
versprechen schreibt das wirklich
einfach alle dinge kommentare junge
scheiße ich fühl mich das echt so kacke
weil ich irgendwie denke dass ich hier
total am arsch sein werde weil ich noch
nicht so richtig geschlossen dann
gekriegt hab ja was bei mir auch so
durch sekunde sind halt schon ein
bisschen knapp 30 sekunden vor allem 130
minuten
ich suche schon die ganze zeit ach ja
richtig auch übrigens etwa
das war ist richtig und nötig was machst
du denn ich wollte mir in eimer holen um
nicht darunter zu bauen sicher aber habe
damit einfach richtig viel zeit
verschwendet man kann den jungs so das
wasser weg nehmen erika ich gehe es rund
um eine schlucht
wenn ich wartet besser noch ein bisschen
mit dem okay der botschafter weiter
ich mach mir mal sicherheitshalber hier
noch so ein ding was ich jetzt machen
werde
so also man wir sind ja echt intensiv
schnell am kräften
zumindest wenn max kann ich das nicht zu
bezeugen ja aber bei mir ist ja klar ich
muss einfach jetzt mal wieder auf die
links runter auf die stelle da unten
holen wir uns dann zueinander tippen wie
denn mit fdp bla bla bla bla ja wie ich
würde sagen einer läuft in mitte wir
laufen beide so einer teleportiert sich
zum anderen und anlauf mit zusammen der
mitte jemand starten wir den fall da
darf man nichts mehr verändern oder so
an seinen sachen ja und dann wirst du so
neben mir laufen zu merken falter fakt
nicht mehr [ __ ] ist eine krasse
sachen habe da werde ich dann denken
definitiv die nied ii genitiv heißt
alter die hier das lied so richtig nach
links aus nach krefeld natürlich das
alles vergessen was ich eigentlich
mitnehmen wollte nach diamanten
ich hab erst fünf gefunden deswegen wird
sie soll wenn der wenn er sein steak ist
bei mir sieht das aus als werde auf
speed alter junge der zombie hat wird
nicht voll gepusht hundezone nämlich
hätten sie gar keine monster ich glaub
ich geh gleich auch noch mal kurz eine
hürde so fünf minuten
du bist in keiner höhle warum sucht die
auf der bank ist er für mich in der
höhle
ich suche also höhere 12 meine taktik
ist das einzigste was luca kann bei
battles diaz finden wobei ich nicht
besser im mund nicht zu voll leben habe
ich auch schon mal auf der maur bekommen
luca es gut bei dir da hinten ist nix
das onyx das aber weniger wenn schon wer
da hinten glaube ich was einfach fast
den lava gefallen junge ja ich hätte ich
hab's vergessen shift zurückweist hat
man zwar nicht so gesehen aber
vielleicht so kurz davor doch wenn ich
sterbe ich glaub ich sage einfach nix
bis dahin steht luca daten dann warte
ich dein lachen ab
redstone das sind immer die es in der
nähe seiner rede klar fürs alter ich
kein cannabis schwert machen
love is ne scheiße ich glaube ich
relativ ich meine höhle
die anderen anspannung ich habe richtig
angst dass irgendwelche monster hierher
kommt richtig angst dass ich mich durch
übels erschreckt oder ja geil ist bringt
einfach nichts ändern würde
das bringt nichts weiter herum zu laufen
ok ja ich hoffe sogar richtige wackelte
minecraft geil willst du mein nachbar
denkt ich bin behindert
danke sagt sie du sagst mir sie zu mir
die jungs mal als ich glaub mich zwei
blöcke weiter ich bin direkt in der
höhle also doch und sagt so gerade in
die höhle also online gut für dich hat
ich mache mir jetzt machen die rüstung
was du für keine flyer in polen war ich
noch nicht bis jetzt wackelt ich glaube
sogar wenn wir beide die gleiche
richtung haben dann wird könnte es sogar
eventuell du gewinnen es ist wirklich
wie stets mindeste ich habe noch ein
paar vorkehrungen abseits der standard
sachen getroffen werde ich mich gleich
an kümmern brauche ich allerdings
spenden für ein bogen werde ich machen
eine angel inhalt leidenschaftlich lagen
leider niemals kriegst du denkst du
kriegst du genug sachen für viele eltern
stimmen pfeile broich auch
erich verzauberten einfach mit
unendlichkeit wäre es den den bogen
ach so ja ist gut er macht das recht wo
liegen meine hände frieren ein alter wo
ich hatte immer vor den ofen in
minecraft ist echt krass sind richtig
kalt bei mir ich kann nicht sein dass
japan links wo diamanten sind
ich habe auch keine aber du hast eh
welche hätte ich mal wer weiß
hätte ich mal extra oder so schlossen
gestern mit xperia warum schreibt die
ganze zeit so in den check für deinen
zuschauer so de und sowas wenn du was
sagt man ich habe keinen diamanten kaum
kreidler ehrlich ja weiß ich denn sonst
die durch die guten so ein gedanke hätte
ich meiner mutter mal sagen die jungen
die kommt dann zu dem box.de ist jemand
heißen
ich bin nicht mehr nur alter das ist
schon älter
ja ich habe gebrannt
was bringt mir gold alten brauch ich
gold ab gold bringt einem gar nichts was
nicht ab
es bringt im gold nicht aus ab oder
gibts mir hey du musst du dir sagst ja
nicht ohne grund lügen so baust nicht ab
hey doch komplett grundlos also
infiziert ist das sehr sehr viel wert
grip hast du die explosion gehört
nein nein ich bin 1000 millionen meter
von dem weg junger nächste will ich die
zeit number verlängern weil da ist
minuten schon krass wenig eigentlich nur
woher wir müssen müssen wir uns nicht
gleich mal battle also nicht in die zeit
wird nicht verlängert luca mein sohn ja
okay ich checke mal kurz ab wie viel
zeit wir noch haben fünf minuten genau
als ob doch aus dem thema gestellt oder
ja habe ich elvis professionellen ich
hätte nicht ob mich wenn ich darauf
gekommen
du machst es halt ein bisschen kürzer
als ich jetzt kommen da auch noch
zombies anschlussstellen laaber schluss
stärkt den lover schluss ich habe gesagt
wir stellen uns vor dass das hier
konkreter ist ok weil ärzte aber keine
dias junge junge ich glaub dir kein wort
alter ich werde dann sehen aber jetzt
glaube ich dir erstmal überhaupt nicht
mehr weiß was du gerade bist danke alter
spaß ich liebe dich du mich nicht liebe
dich auch du bist eine hübsche ratte nun
gescheiterte die anspannung steigt junge
ich würde mal gerne die als ihr lieb ist
die reisen des todes nicht einfach sonst
heutige video auch an die oberfläche
meinst du das
ich finde niemals noch nocht pings tiers
in der tat nichts gesagt dass das in die
kamera gezwungen wird die du gar nicht
hast lass meine geschrieben hab ich auch
ja alles eigentlich du bist vorschlag
von kraft
aber ich muss allein gegen essen war
hoch gehen dass man hier noch verhungert
ist dein tag das könnte eigentlich ein
freudiger meine hände die über treffen
sich jedes mal wie kalt die sind aus tag
vor irgendwas zu fressen alter kommt
schon hier müssten zombies seien hier
direkt zu wäre ich dass du dich mein
links hier höhere durch schlechtes
transporter so dass wir jetzt noch mal
richtig oder etwa mehr sprinten alter du
bist mein recht eigentlich direkt bei
den so vom sound her
bei wem bei den zombies komisch
sehr komisch tut mir leid was willst du
schalter oder hörst du sie nun fast
angst vor nähe ich höre die und denken
vielleicht ist ansporn aber das waren
schon viele geräusche weil das im slum
da vorne
ich bewege mich jetzt auch erstmal nach
oben was soll mit slims anfangen luca
kresnik klein bei
kann man ihn werfen das glaube ich für
pisten sticky bis zum 1 es wird nach
draußen ehrlich wenn wir auf der stelle
gegen den bettel bei gott nein wir
lassen das jetzt einfach sagen beim
nächsten tag des battle beginn ein tag
dort auch zehn minuten oder das wird zu
knapp bei mir scheiße zombie junge mann
deswegen nicht so oft dass ich keine
diamanten finde wir wissen nicht
schlechter schauspieler
ich bin des todes angespannt ich muss
jetzt wirklich irgendwie noch die harz
finden irgendwie muss das noch
hinkriegen finden zuschauer dich nicht
ein bisschen dumm wenn die ganze zeit
lamers der ich müsste jetzt schon längst
welche hast junge ohne witz max ich habe
wirklich keine ahnung hast du auch
gesagt als wir so zum fan gebettelt
haben mehr da hatte ich auch keine
doktor ist zu wenig willen oder sind die
slums des todes einfach überall
ohne witz max spielt mal kurz mit
offenen karten
ich habe zwei diaz und ich brauche
einfach ein dritter deswegen bin ich
ganz so angespannt und brauchst den
dritten stern man kann mit zwei diashow
schwert machen nämlich denkt an pekings
junge bist du behindert im kopf wenn
behinderte meinem kopf drin
bolliger mexiko schlachtet hier die
slams warum auch immer
warum auch immer nennt sich wechsel k
warum auch immer nennt er sich wechsel
klar warum david ist formal recht ist
man max code also passt du echt diaz